[Aplausos]
[Música]
rusia fue el primer país del mundo en
crear una vacuna contra el coronavirus
la llamada sputnik v o sea si adelantado
así a toda la industria farmacéutica
mundial y con esta vacuna es con la que
surge el debate podemos fiarnos de la
tecnología médica rusa muchos países
piensan que no
[Música]
para sin rechazar a sputnik y moscú
culpa a eeuu y no brasil no es el único
país ni la unión europea ni eeuu han
aprobado esta vacuna al menos en el
momento en el que hacemos este vídeo y
la pregunta es por qué desconfían de la
sputnik v hay razones médicas o simple y
llanamente hablamos de una cuestión
ideológica no sólo eso la vacuna rusa
eran muchísimas incógnitas por ejemplo
esta putin apoya que rusia renuncia a la
patente de su vacuna de kobe pensadlo
bien porque putin quería renunciar a la
patente de su propia vacuna a fin de
cuentas rusia podría ganar una auténtica
fortuna vendiendo su vacuna a todo el
mundo al final del vídeo responderemos a
esta pregunta mientras tanto la gran
duda que tendréis muchos espero vamos a
ver de verdad funciona el sputnik v o
simplemente es una maniobra de
propaganda rusa pues veréis en visual
polític no somos expertos en vacunas así
que nos tenemos que fiar de lo que dicen
las revistas científicas como la
británica delante
en febrero de este año 2021 de lance
publicó un estudio con 20.000
participantes y demostraron que la
vacuna rusa tiene una eficacia del 91,6
por ciento es decir que en principio
todo apunta a que la sputnik v funciona
sin embargo hoy en día sólo 64 países la
han aprobado y la mayoría están en
latinoamérica oriente medio y áfrica los
países más ricos del mundo siguen sin
fiarse de la medicina rusa y todo esto
puede ser muy sospechoso porque a fin de
cuentas la sputnik v fue la primera
vacuna en ser anunciada
[Música]
en agosto de 2020 cuando todo el planeta
tierra estaba desesperado por encontrar
una vacuna rusia presentó a su flamante
candidata varios meses después tanto
europa como eeuu siguen discutiendo
sobre si deberían utilizarla o no y
muchos pensaréis que hay un doble rasero
a fin de cuentas tanto la vacuna de fai
serpiente como la de moderna se
aprobarán a las pocas semanas de
anunciarse cuál es el problema real con
la vacuna rusa porque hay tanta gente
que desconfía de ella hablamos de
ciencia o hablamos de política cómo es
posible que rusia se haya adelantado al
mundo entero incluyendo a toda la
industria farmacéutica mundial y porque
la minera putin está dispuesto a
renunciar a la patente hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver fotos de historia
ride ingrassia la primera pregunta que
os estaréis haciendo todos es de dónde
viene el nombre de sputnik v pues veréis
en ruso sputnik significa compañero de
viaje y recuerda los mejores momentos de
rusia
[Aplausos]
por eso la agencia de noticias
internacional rusa también se llama
sputnik news y la vacuna que rusia
quiere vender al mundo entero se llama
la sputnik y por cierto la ub no es de
cinco sino de vacuna y diréis pero de
verdad la ciencia rusa es tan importante
como aparece y lo cierto es que si por
ejemplo sabéis quién creó el primer
reactor nuclear del mundo pues no no
fueron científicos estadounidenses sino
el señor y un científico ruso
a lo largo de todo el siglo 21 rusia ha
dado a muchos de los mejores científicos
de la historia y ya se lo que estaréis
pensando muchos pero como es posible no
se supone que la unión soviética era un
volador de repente nos vas a decir aquí
fonseca en visual político que el
comunismo funciona haber tranquilos la
ventaja de tener una economía
centralizada es que si el estado decide
invertir en una tecnología puede poner
un montón de dinero de golpe lo hacían
con el comunismo y lo hacen con el
optimismo por eso el armamento ruso es
tan bueno por ahora de ellos son los
misiles es de 400
- según dicen los expertos están al
mismo nivel que sus equivalentes en eeuu
y esto exactamente esto es lo mismo que
ocurrió con el instituto gamma leia
[Música]
recuerdan bien su nombre porque este es
el instituto donde se desarrolló la
vacuna rusa sputnik v es un instituto
fundado en 1891 y nacionalizado en 1919
en occidente se sabe muy poco de este
centro y es normal rusia no es
precisamente famosa por dar a conocer
sus actividades y ser muy transparente
pero lo cierto es que cuando las
farmacéuticas capitalistas se
preocupaban por otros medicamentos más
comerciales y no por las vacunas gamal
ella ya investigaba vacunas para virus
que asolaban el tercer mundo como el
ébola curar el ébola en áfrica es muy
poco rentable para una empresa privada
pero gamal ella no busca el beneficio
económico y eso en este caso les ha dado
una ventaja competitiva enorme economía
estatal una economía de mercado cero
y lo mismo pasa con el dinero al ser una
economía tan centralizada el estado
tiene muchísimo dinero para poderlo
poner donde haga falta y que han hecho
pues para esto entra en escena una
persona con todo el respaldo del kremlin
atentos
[Música]
hablamos de kirill dmítriev ucraniano de
45 años que estudia en las universidades
más prestigiosas de los eeuu pero que
ahora se ha colocado en el bando opuesto
y es el ceo del fondo soberano ruso y si
habéis oído bien al igual que noruega
tiene su fondo soberano rusia también
tiene uno que es más pequeño pero lo
suficientemente grande como para
invertir la friolera de 10.000 millones
de dólares para desarrollar la vacuna
que el mundo entero estaba esperando
eeuu se sobresaltó al oír zumbar al
sputnik va a ocurrir lo mismo con esta
vacuna rusia va a llegar primero kiril
limítrofe o del fondo ruso de inversión
directa así que con tanto dinero tantos
años y con tantísimo optimismo como
destila este personaje no es casualidad
en agosto del año 2020 ocurriera lo
siguiente
[Música]
putin asegura que rusia tiene la primera
vacuna aprobada contra la cob y 19
habéis oído bien el 11 de agosto la spot
de uva fue la primera vacuna autorizada
en todo el planeta para el uso de
emergencia esta aprobación se dio
únicamente por parte del gobierno ruso y
en base a los estudios de las primeras
dos fases fueron publicados por delante
creéis que todo el mundo vería con
buenos ojos esta autorización pues
evidentemente no está decisión fue
criticada por muchos porque pues porque
aún faltaban los datos finales de los
ensayos clínicos de las últimas fases y
ahí es cuando se iniciaron una serie de
dudas cómo es posible que rusia pudiera
sacar una vacuna antes mucho antes que
otros países en principio más avanzados
como eeuu o reino unido
vamos a decirlo claro en aquel momento
prácticamente nadie se tomó en serio la
vacuna rusa empezando por nosotros aquí
en visual político pero seamos honestos
a medida que se hicieron pruebas se
descubrió que la vacuna funcionaba no
sólo eso que es más barata que las
competidoras fijaos bien una bolita
incube cuesta 10 dólares esto es un 60%
más barata que la de moderna y un 50%
más barata que la de facer es decir
misma eficacia pero precios más bajos y
sobre todo logística más barata en otras
palabras la sputnik v es la vacuna más
competitiva rusia podría comerse el
mercado internacional si quisiera sin
embargo y aquí llega la primera sorpresa
putin está a favor de renunciar a la
patente es decir que cualquiera en
cualquier parte del mundo podría
fabricar esta vacuna sin tener que pagar
un royalty al instituto gamal ella
porque rusia quería renunciar a
tantísimo dinero pues tranquilos porque
vamos a responder a esa pregunta más
adelante antes tenemos que entender el
auténtico problema de la vacuna rosa
la otra cara de una economía
centralizada la pregunta que todos
estáis haciendo ahora es cómo han podido
fabricar vacunas tan rápido si seguís
visual político ya sabéis que no basta
con tener una buena fórmula para crear
una vacuna también hay que fabricar la y
esto es un proceso realmente complicado
para que os hagáis una idea a finales de
2020 una empresa tan grande y con
tantísima experiencia como falset decían
que eran capaces de fabricar solamente
1100 millones de dosis a lo largo de
este año 2021
de hecho las campañas de vacunación se
han ralentizado en europa por falta de
suministros entonces cómo es posible que
de repente en rusia hayan podido
producir vacunas para sus casi 144
millones de habitantes y que además
ahora puedan ponerse a exportar tan
rápido
respuesta rápida no no pueden fabricar
tantas vacunas para que os hagáis una
idea en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo rusia solo tiene a un 6% de
la población vacunada fijaos en este
gráfico israel tiene al 59 por ciento de
su población vacunada eeuu el 37 por
ciento reino unido- el 30 por ciento y
la unión europea se encuentra con un 13
por ciento es decir que rusia está muy
por detrás pese a tener su patente como
es posible entonces que rusia esté tan
preocupada por vender vacunas cuando
todavía no tiene ni para su propia
población pues bien esta es la primera
gran duda que tienen muchos políticos
atentos
seguimos preguntándonos por qué rusia
ofrece teóricamente millones y millones
de dosis mientras no avanza lo
suficiente en la vacunación de su propio
pueblo
úrsula von der leyen presidente de la
comisión europea como os podéis imaginar
la propaganda rusa y creedme hay un
montón de propaganda rusa con respecto a
esta vacuna dice que europa tiene
prejuicios contra los rusos sin embargo
muchos países europeos han llegado a
negociar compras vacunas rusas por su
cuenta y creedme en este caso la
ideología y los prejuicios tienen muy
pero que muy poco que ver atentos
isabel díaz ayuso presidenta de la
comunidad de madrid seguirá negociando
la compra de la vacuna rusa para
acelerar la inmunidad de madrid los que
veáis este vídeo desde españa ya
conocéis a la señora isabel díaz ayuso
acaba de salir reelegida en unas
elecciones donde su eslogan era
comunismo o libertad si hay una política
que podría tener algún tipo de fobia
contra rusia y todo lo que representa
esa es sin duda alguna la señora isabel
díaz ayuso sin embargo en lo que a bajo
una respecta a la ideología importa más
bien poco pero ojo que no sólo hablamos
de negociaciones hay países que ya han
pasado de las palabras a los hechos y
uno de ellos es eslovaquia
[Música]
eslovaquia segundo país de la unión
europea en recibirla sputnik
y justo en eslovaquia es donde han
empezado los problemas porque veréis
sobre el papel la sputnik es una vacuna
fantástica pero cuando eslovaquia
analiza las 200.000 dosis entregadas por
rusia llegaron a esta triste conclusión
y estas vacunas lo único que tienen en
común con la fórmula original es el
nombre instituto estatal de control de
medicamentos en otras palabras una cosa
es cuando lo pides al instituto gamal
ella y otra muy distinta cuando te llega
para que os hagáis una idea este
incidente de la vacuna ha sido toda una
bomba política en eslovaquia de hecho el
primer ministro eslovaco tuvo que
dimitir por las críticas recibidas por
comprar la vacuna rusa ha sido un
auténtico fracaso de su gobierno además
las autoridades sanitarias de este país
todavía se quejan de que apenas les han
enviado información sobre la vacuna
y aquí es donde llegamos a la otra cara
de la economía centralizada lo que
podríamos llamar el efecto chernóbil es
cierto el estado ruso puede pagar una
fortuna a los institutos estatales para
que desarrollen la vacuna la pregunta es
quién la fabrica y aquí es cuando entra
un concepto clave en economía la cadena
de valor es decir un científico puede
descubrir una fórmula para fabricar
vacunas pero para fabricar la necesitas
cientos de empresas fábricas de vacunas
proveedores empresas de logística
hablamos de una red enorme de empresas
interconectadas
por supuesto que desde el estado se
pueden imponer controles de calidad y
regulaciones pero es casi imposible
crear toda esa red de proveedores desde
cero y cuando se hace suele salir mal de
hecho eso es exactamente lo que ocurrió
con el accidente de chernóbil chernóbil
tenía una tecnología puntera ya os digo
que los físicos nucleares soviéticos no
tenían nada que envidiar a los
estadounidenses sin embargo había dos
problemas el primero es que los
reactores no estaban pensados para uso
civil sino para uso militar el segundo
era la puesta en práctica porque para
abaratar los costes los constructores de
la central se saltaron unos cuantos
controles de calidad por cierto aquí
tengo que hacer un paréntesis
muchas gracias a operador nuclear por
asesorar me en esta parte le podéis
seguir en twitter por aquí de nuevo una
cosa era la central nuclear que pedía
senna libres y otra muy distinta lo que
te llegaba y diréis pero bueno es que
nadie se dio vuelta pues probablemente
sí pero vamos a ver quién se atrevería a
decirle al político de turno que ha
tomado una mala decisión si todo esto le
puede llevar a la cárcel si algo
caracteriza a las dictaduras es la falta
de transparencia y eso significa
procesos poco eficientes en la mayor
parte de los casos todo esto se traduce
en mucho
sobre costes y falta de competitividad
pero en el caso de chernobyl en fin pues
todos sabemos lo que pasó así que
volvemos a la pregunta de antes cómo es
posible que rusia y ha sido capaz de
fabricar tantísimas vacunas en tan poco
tiempo y la respuesta es que no rusia no
tiene una industria farmacéutica capaz
de fabricar tantísimas vacunas en masa
pero a la vez quiere vender vacunas al
mercado internacional
conclusión pues que muchas de las dosis
que se han vendido no han pasado todos
los controles de calidad necesarios y
esto por no decir otra cosa peor sucedió
en eslovaquia y podría suceder en otros
países dicho de otra manera hay un
océano de diferencia cuando lo pides al
instituto gamal ella y cuando te llega y
ya se lo que estaréis pensando muchos ya
están de nuevo los de visual político
criticando a rusia que nos ha pagado
para hacer este vídeo pues no a ver
tranquilos ahora viene la parte
realmente buena de la vacuna rusa ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
porque rusia no quiere patentes boutique
v es la única vacuna que cuenta con su
propia página web y hasta su perfil de
twitter perfil de twitter que incluso
llega a poner en ridículo las otras
vacunas es un marketing puro y duro y lo
cierto es que toda esta maquinaria de
propaganda está funcionando
argentina recibe el nuevo cargamento de
vacunas sputnik
y suma en total 4 38 millones de dosis
contra kobe
llena la india el primer lote de la
vacuna rusa sputnik v y diréis pero
fonseca porque compran la sputnik y no
otras vacunas esta respuesta se resume
en dos palabras ideología y necesidad
tanto argentina como india tienen lazos
ideológicos y culturales con rusia pero
de eso hablaremos en otro vídeo cierto
es que tanto india como argentina no
pueden comprar las vacunas super caras
de facer y modernas además casi toda la
producción de estas empresas ya está
vendida a los países ricos como la unión
europea israel o eeuu
conclusión que la vacuna rusa les viene
como anillo al dedo además en varios
estudios se ha demostrado que funciona y
existe incluso un caso de éxito real un
país que parece haber acabado ya con la
pandemia gracias a la ayuda del kremlin
y grace en serio qué país te refieres
fonseca pues atentos
[Música]
un submarino primer país de europa en
vencer lakovic 19 con sputnik v pensadlo
bien hablamos de un micro estado de tan
solo 34 mil personas es decir que es
relativamente fácil fabricar vacunas
para toda su población sin necesidad de
tener grandes empresas farmacéuticas en
el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
el 90% de la población de san marino ya
está vacunada y no han tenido ni una
sola muerte desde el 27 de abril es
decir que en principio parece que está
funcionando y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos vale es posible fabricar
vacunas en un micro estado incluso se
pueden poner controles de calidad para
un lote de 60.000 vacunas pero qué pasa
cuando hablamos de países grandes como
argentina o la india de verdad es
posible que rusia garantice la calidad
de tantísimos millones de vacunas como
lo van a hacer pues atentos
maestra técnica y el instituto gama ley
ya firmaron un memorándum de cooperación
con el objetivo de hacer uso de todas
las posibilidades de cooperación
internacional para acercar la victoria
sobre la infección en otras palabras que
rusia pone la ciencia y astrazéneca las
fábricas y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos en este momento
estratégica pero no se supone que
astrazéneca tiene ya su propia vacuna
porque querrían desarrollar las vacunas
de otros pues si tenéis razón por lo que
parece astrazéneca va a fabricar ambas
vacunas la suya y la de rusia pero ojo
porque esto no es suficiente para que
rusia pueda distribuir su vacuna en
países tan grandes como la india y aquí
llega la respuesta que estabais
esperando la respuesta a la pregunta del
inicio del vídeo porque rusia está
dispuesta a renunciar a su patente
puesto esto
rusia e india pactan producir 200
millones de vacunas sputnik
al año nos ya está buscando producir su
vacuna en masa y para eso necesita
asociarse con cuantas más farmacéuticas
como sea posible no hablamos de grandes
nombres como facer sino de empresas
dedicadas a la fabricación de
medicamentos genéricos para que os
hagáis una idea en china ya hay acuerdos
con empresas para producir 260 millones
de vacunas en argentina- los
laboratorios richmond producirán 100
millones de dosis
os podéis imaginar si rusia regala la
patente o la pone un precio muy barato
será mucho más fácil encontrar empresas
que la fabriquen sobre todo en los
países de renta más baja a cambio el
kremlin va a tener muchísima más
influencia en zonas como latinoamérica o
la india pero no sólo eso gracias a
todos estos acuerdos rusia también podrá
producir vacunas suficientes como para
inmunizar a su propia población
[Aplausos]
no olvidéis este gráfico aquí podéis ver
como sólo el 6% de los rusos está
vacunado con una población de más de 144
millones de personas rusia necesita
fabricar millones de dosis en muy poco
tiempo es decir que por encima del
dinero de la geopolítica la prioridad
del kremlin es conseguir que se
fabriquen vacunas suficientes para los
propios rusos pensadlo bien cuanta más
gente esté fabricando la sputnik ub en
todo el mundo más rápido podrán
conseguir vacunas para sus propios
habitantes pero todo esto sería un tema
mucho más complejo para desarrollar en
otro vídeo porque en lo que a salud
pública respecta la vacuna rusa puede
ser una muy buena noticia para todos
ahora bien su efectividad va a depender
mucho de quien la fabrique habrá países
con laboratorios con mejores controles
de calidad que otros así que muy
probablemente tenemos países donde la
sputnik sirve para acabar con la
pandemia rápidamente y países donde haya
algún que otro problema
[Música]
en cualquier caso todo esto son
suposiciones ahora llega el turno para
vosotros creéis que la unión europea y
eeuu terminarán aprobando la vacuna rusa
en qué medida puede servir esta vacuna
la sputnik para aumentar la influencia
de rusia en todo el mundo podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que aquí en
visual político sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribimos a
este canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]